hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in lecture two of
his work pragmatism William James is
going to set out the outlines of the
pragmatic theory of truth which he
distinguishes from the closely connected
pragmatic method of examining ideas or
resolving disputes here he's focused
more on well what do we mean to say that
something is true or correspondingly to
call it false and James is not fully
flushing this out he defers that to
later lectures but he is giving us some
really important outlines pragmatism has
often been summed up as the theory that
truth is just what works or what
somebody would like to be true or finds
useful and that's not entirely true and
I mean true not just in the pragmatic
sense but in other senses that people
use using that term quite
self-consciously there that's not really
true of James's position which is a bit
more complex than that and which is
placed in relation to not just his own
philosophy and psychology it's important
to remember he is a psychologist nor
that
his predecessor Charles Sanders purse
and his contemporary John Dewey but also
a lot of working scientists of the time
there's this pragmatic conception of
truth is in fact quite a popular one
when we look at it quite carefully so I
think it's useful before we delve into
what James says explicitly about this as
a theory of truth to think about the
narratives that he is providing us here
in part because he tells us that
pragmatism is in fact a genetic theory
of truth and what is a genetic theory of
truth mean it's kind of similar to what
in other places people like say you know
Friedrich Nietzsche would call a
genealogical conception right hey
Jeanette ik theory of truth is one that
that traces out how something came to be
viewed as true and it's largely going to
be in terms of human interests and needs
and and what manages to fit itself in
with other things that are acknowledged
as true so he talks first about laws of
nature and he's not saying anything
that's truly controversial here if you
know something about the history of
ideas in the history of science he tells
us that writers on the subject of
inductive logic have began to show a
single singular unanimity as to what the
laws of nature and elements of fact mean
when formulated by mathematicians
physicists and and chemists so we're
talking here about something that's a
very pure discipline and then something
that's you know still very abstract
physics although now it's studying
material things and then chemistry we're
starting to get you know more and more
along the spectrum at which will lead us
into biology and then into other things
like the social sciences so he says that
when the first mathematical logical and
natural uniformity is the first laws
were discovered men were so carried away
by the clearness beauty and
simplification that result
said that they believed themselves to
have deciphered authentically the
eternal thoughts of the Almighty or if
we don't have to be the Almighty it
could be nature it could be they've
they've gained an understanding of the
universe somebody who this would be
applying to would be you know the great
not just philosopher but also
mathematician Rene Descartes right in
his early works he talks about having
discovered that mathematics could
possibly be the basis for everything and
so he says that the these people's mind
thundered and reverberating and Sylla
Chisholm's they also thought in conic
sections squares and roots and ratios
and geometry geometries like Euclid he
made Kepler's laws for the planets to
follow he made velocity increase
proportionately to the time and falling
bodies when we can go on and on and on
he's giving all these great examples
he thought the archetypes of all things
and devised their variations and when we
rediscover any one of these wondrous
institutions we seize his mind the
divine mind and it's very literal
intention or nature or the cosmos or
whatever we want it to be and that is in
fact a picture of the sciences that I
think a lot of people still have today
because a lot of people love the
sciences with a certain sort of
superstition they don't actually know
much about science they've you know
learn some things in their science
classes in high school and you know from
reading Wikipedia or les wrong or pick
whatever other site you want these are
the people who are science logic reason
you know constantly bombarding you with
appeals to those sort of things but if
we actually look at the history of the
development of science and we read
people who were scientists and expressed
their own their own you know thoughts
about what they were doing
turns out the story takes a different
turn he says that as the science has
developed farther the notion has gained
ground that most perhaps all of our laws
are only approximations the laws
themselves have grown so numerous there
is no counting them many rival
formulations are proposed in all the
branches of science that investigators
have become accustomed
the notion that here's the key no theory
is absolutely a transcript of reality
but any one of them may from some point
of view be useful there's the key a
realization that what we want with
theories is not sort of having a
blueprint in our mind of the reality out
there just for the sake of doing so for
the sake of truth alone you might say
but so that we can do things now this
goes all the way back to say bacon
you know the idea of studying nature so
that we can actually do something with
nature of course he wanted to dominate
it perhaps we don't necessarily need to
go to that rhetoric that could be part
of an advance you know maybe we don't
want to dominate so we find other ways
of understanding nature that don't
require us to do that he goes on and
James goes on and says that the great
use of theories is to summarize old
facts and lead to new ones they're only
a man-made language a conceptual
shorthand in which we write our reports
of nature and languages as is well known
tolerate much choice of expression in
many dialects and he goes on and he says
human arbitrariness is driven to divine
necessity from scientific logic human
arbitrariness being our desires our
needs our wishes what it is that we're
trying to do with ideas and then he
bring he does a bit of named wrapping
here bringing up people who some of you
will have heard of but many of these you
won't have Sid Wert mock Ostwald Pearson
mill hog Wong Kar do him Royce and right
and and he's talking to people who know
these at the time we could bring up
other scientists of our own time very
few of them buy into their being like a
truth that's out there static for all
time for us to discover and and many of
them have a more pragmatic attitude
towards that so there's a story that's
being told here about how we've gone
from an earlier point of view which was
less adequate to a more adequate point
of view and this is a genetic story a
little bit later on he talks about
ancient truths
and he says that the observable process
which Schiller and Dewey both of them
being being philosophers here singled
out for generalization is the familiar
one by which any individual settles into
new opinions and we're gonna look at
that elsewhere and he talks about these
processes of truths growth there are in
fact older truths things that have been
around for a very long time he says
Dewey and Schiller proceeded to
generalize the observation that we're
gonna look at in just a moment and to
apply it to the most ancient parts of
truth they all they were once plastic
they were true for human reasons they
mediated between earlier truths and what
in that day were novel observations so
you know pretty much everything that we
nowadays accept somebody had to come up
with that idea and at first a lot of
people rejected it but other people were
like maybe there's something to that
I'll try that on and the things that
were successfully accepted were the
things that were successfully applied or
adapted within the framework of what we
had and every once in a while old truths
fall out sort of like dead skin cells
falling away and they're replaced by new
ones again genetic theory of truth and
ancient truths that were once plastic
and then become sort of ossified can
also be reinterpreted in ways that make
them once again living and flexible so
this is an important narrative that's
being spelled out here now let's look at
you know sort of the nuts and bolts of
this theory James says that Dewey and
all of his allies as he calls them
misters Dewey's Shiller and their allies
are following the example of geologists
biologists and philologists right they
are saying that the truth is going to be
what we can what we can use and and
here's the key idea ideas are true just
so far as they help us to get into
satisfactory relation with other parts
of our experience this is
Dewey's formulation that James is
bringing up here now Dewey is a rather
opaque author people who read him often
come away quite confused and looking at
this passage you might say well that's
confusing too so let's let's break it
down what's actually being said their
ideas these are things that we have in
our mind and also have in language and
to some degree also have in action they
are also part of experience they are
true according to the pragmatic theory
of truth or as Dewey calls it the
instrumentalist view insofar as they
help us the people who are actually
going to say that they're true to get
into satisfactory relation with other
parts of our experience they help us to
make sense out of the world and they're
not just functioning in an explanatory
way they're also functioning functioning
in an action guiding sort of way I'll
give you just a prime example taken from
personal life I come in
you know from teaching and I find that
the dog is instead of laying by the door
waiting for me to come in is lying on
her side panting and moaning and I think
well what's what's going on here this is
unusual right and so that's part of my
experience already I already have a
whole range of experience lying behind
me which includes the fact that the dog
in question is a glutton who will eat
whatever she can to the degree that she
can if we for example leave the the the
top to the food container open she will
use her mouth like a shovel pull out
food
spit it out out of the floor gobble it
all up she will eat pounds and pounds of
it because she has done that in the past
right that's part of my experience and
so you know I I immediately start
thinking to myself she's probably gotten
into the food thing I'd better go check
that and let's say I know I do that and
nope there's it's a there's no
around and the top is not often even if
it was she couldn't go in there now I
started thinking about other things well
what what could be going on here maybe
she fell down and hurt herself or
perhaps she's sick and now this leads me
to doing sort of a diagnostic as best as
I can and then probably taking her to
the emergency of that right these are
all ways in which ideas are being made
true in process to make sense out of the
experiences that we're having and the
matrix of other experiences that we use
to you know our memories to make sense
of the experiences of the present so
hopefully that example helps you out a
little bit so ideas are true so insofar
as they help us they assist us they fit
into satisfactory relation we know when
we don't have satisfactory relations
because in the realm of you know the
speculative we are bothered by the fact
that we can't make sense of things or we
don't understand them or we're stuck in
doubt we know in the sense of the the
practical ranges when we were in
satisfactory relation when we can say
yes I am actually happy with this as
opposed to being irritated vexed or we
can say well I'm irritated but I'm okay
with this being irritated that would be
satisfactory relation now he also talks
about this as saying that things are
true for just so much true in so far
forth true instrumentally right truth is
not something that is like you know a
Hosanna on high coming down from the
clouds once and for all instead it's
it's true to a certain extent it's true
in so far forth it's true instrumentally
as we can use it and James is going to
contrast this as all the pragmatist will
against what he calls a rationalist
conception of truth which by the way
many philosophical empiricists would
also
be representing as would be the people
who today talk about the correspondence
theory of truth and don't mean by it
what philosophers actually mean which is
a particular understanding of truth and
instead elevate it to mean this gigantic
worldview where there's only
correspondence theory and nothing else
right that would be an example of what
James is combating here and he he goes
on and he calls this truth independent
truth that we find merely truth no
longer malleable to human need truth
incorrigible in a word such truth who
says exists indeed super abundantly or
is supposed to exist by rationally
rationalistic aliy minded thinkers and
then he likens this to the dead heart of
the living tree now that means that it
has some sort of usefulness right the
heart of the tree any given tree is
mostly dead wood and the growing stuff
is on the outside is it not that's where
the tree contacts reality the dead wood
is useful because it supports it stays
in place by its very rigidity but it's
dead it's not going to do anything for
you
I suppose you could say well it's great
for like when we want to make you know
chalkboard frames or burn wood or things
like that
right but not that good for the for the
you know the tree to be entirely dead
right so he says that this is only the
dead heart of the living tree it's being
there means only that truth has its
paleontology and its prescriptions and
may grow stiff with years of veteran
service and petrified in men's regard by
sheer antiquity and so he's saying here
we want to we don't want to say that
there's no point whatsoever to this
notion of truth but this is sort of
static truth is eternal truth is you
know whatever remains purely objective
in all the circumstances totally you
know independent of our interests and
needs and desires it does actually serve
a purpose it does have a legitimacy
but that's not pragmatic truth pragmatic
truth is this you know truth as an
instrument and he will end here by
saying that one way of thinking about
this
is that truth he says becomes a class
name for all sorts of definite working
values in experience for the rationalist
it remains a pure abstraction to the
bare name of which we must defer what
when the pragmatist undertakes to show
in detail just why we must defer the
rationalist is unable to recognize the
concrete's from which his own
abstraction is taken he accuses us of
denying truth whereas we have only
sought to trace exactly why people
follow it and always ought to follow it
so that you know truth for the
pragmatist it's still something very
important and indeed quite robust but
it's supposed to be serving human
interest needs and desires and driven by
them and perhaps even revealing them in
relation to other interest desires and
other truths it's supposed to be a much
more flexible and organic conception of
truth that does justice to the ways in
which ordinary people and philosophers
and contemporary scientists use the
conception of true and false
you